[Music]
you knew him didn't you
then you had that one little feeling
but you waved it away
[Music]
you should have listened to that one
little feeling just like i'm listening
to you now
you can talk to me i'm all a friend
you're not exactly a department favorite
things probably changed a lot since you
left
you still got to catch them right yeah
not that much exchange then
i can assure you all we are taking a 24
7 all hands on deck approach to these
cases
guy's a shark if he stops he dies he
likes to drive probably has a decent car
maybe two
high mileage they must really like my
car
i do how's the trunk space
something i gotta know how's the guy
with the best clearance rate in the
department worked 15 years without a
promotion
maybe i didn't go to the right church
when i look in your eyes what i see
it ain't good
[Music]
he knew all the details but he wasn't
within 10 miles of the killing
why ain't that why is that
[Music]
how's the trunk space
[Music]
what do you want i want to nail the
bastard for
all of the girls he killed
[Music]
i want to know difference is
i'm doing this for me
[Music]
it's little things jimmy so little
things that rip you apart it's the
little things that
get you caught
[Music]
foreign